ce sont des résultats encourageants
le vaccin expérimental a déclenché la
production d'un niveau élevé d'anticorps
contre le coc vie de 19 chez les
participants c'est ce qu'a permis
d'observer la première phase de l'essai
du groupe américain moderna le vaccin
entre donc dans la phase finale de son
essai clinique pour tester son
efficacité dans des conditions réelles
c'est une façon prudente et progressive
de faire les choses tout d'abord avec un
petit groupe de jeunes personnes
ensuite vous l'élargisse et aux
personnes plus âgées puisque cela a très
bien fonctionné dans le groupe des plus
jeunes il faudra voir comment les
personnes plus âgées réagissent nous
savons qu'ils ne réagissent généralement
pas aussi bien au bac 5 il est plus
jeune c'est donc un aspect que nous
examinerons très attentivement une étape
déterminante qui sera réalisé avec la
participation de 30 mille américains
la moitié d'entre eux recevront une dose
de 100 microgrammes du vaccin
les autres se verront injecter un
placebo les chercheurs suivront ensuite
les patients durant deux ans pour
déterminer s'ils sont protégés contre le
coc vie 19
une bonne nouvelle selon anthony fauci
le plus aux experts en maladies
infectieuses de l'administration
américaine
si votre vaccin peut apporter une
réaction comparable à une infection
naturel
c'est une victoire c'est pourquoi nous
sommes très satisfaits des résultats
si la dose retenu pour les essais
s'annonce efficace moderna prévoit de
produire 500 millions de doses par an le
groupe américain se prépare à produire à
plus grande échelle jusqu'à 1 milliard
d'unités moderna n'est pas la seule
entreprise lancée dans une course contre
la montre pour trouver un vaccin
la compagnie chinoise sinovac biotech en
seraient à un stade avancé de ses
recherches en russie le centre de
recherche en épidémiologie et
microbiologie de moscou a annoncé avoir
achevé les essais cliniques d'un futur
vaccin
mais pour le moment aucune donnée n'a
été rendue publique